So, here we are in the Jenkins console.
Even without logging in, we can look at
various projects that it's been set up
to build, like adventure.
This project is watching a GitHub
repo for another Udacity course, and
every time a student checks in,
in addition to that repo,
this Jenkins instance recompiles it.
You can see the history of it
over here under build history.
Now, if we go back to the main page, and
login, then we'll be able to
access the server wide settings.
For instance,
here are the security settings that let
us say what users are allowed to do.
And over here is the list of plugins.
Jenkins is kind of
a plugin based system.
Everything you want to do,
such as pull from GitHub or
run JUnit tests or various other
things is there on a plugin.
Now that we're logged in,
let's take another look at
that adventure build target.
Under the project configuration,
you can see the name,
there can be a description, here's
what repository it's gotten from with
a GitHub URL here, and
down here is the build schedule.
It says how often the build can be
run if Jenkins notices changes.
H/15 in this field means that it
should be run every 15 minutes.
And down here you can see the build
script that's actually being run.
Turns out that this is just a mockup.
And it runs the disk usage,
or du Unix command.
If this were a real build it would
probably run compilation and
packaging here.
And then if we look in
an individual build
at the console output we can
see the output of that script.
Having this kind of log from every
compilation is really handy.
Suppose that something had
gone wrong ten builds ago,
would you rather be diagnosing
that from someone's email saying,
something broke and I don't know what?
Or from a log file,
that says exactly what's going on?